bom então pessoal quando a gente pensa
empreendedorismo foi a primeira imagem
que vem na nossa cabeça que a gente
pensa
um jovem de 20 anos 20 e poucos anos que
empreendeu ao gigante milhares de
usuários
milhares de pessoas ou quem sabe um
bilionário do petróleo que fez muito
dinheiro com essa commodity
mas o que ninguém pensa é que também nas
comunidades
existem muitas pessoas com uma
capacidade incrível de empreender gerar
valor e gerar oportunidades e que elas
muitas vezes não têm a chance de
conseguir tocar o seu sonho mas às vezes
as ideias às nossas agregam ao
conhecimento as ferramentas necessárias
para aquelas que possam realmente
empreender
então o projeto semear sonho ele surgiu
justamente para isso para capacitar
empreendedores de baixa renda a fomentar
o seu potencial empreendedor e construir
soluções para suas realidades
então esse projeto não seria possível
sem a ajuda de diversos atores um
características distintas com ideias
diferentes e por isso as mãos verdes em
parceria com a ufrgs e diversas outras
empresas e outros voluntários se uniram
em torno da causa empreendedora popular
é isso foi muito importante para
desenvolver essas idéias dentro das
comunidades
eu faço um agradecimento especial à
professora stephanie da ufrgs é o meu
sócio ao seu nascimento que montar em
realizar essa ideia comigo mas falando
um pouquinho mais através do programa
todos somos porto alegre
a gente identificou 500 potenciais
empreendedores nas comunidades de porto
alegre mas poucos tinham realmente
aquele perfil empreendedor
aquelas pessoas que realmente tinha
capacidade de transformar o seu negócio
na prática
então a gente conseguiu com isso
encontrar esses empreendedores
mas o que significa isso
o empreendedor o que diferencia por
exemplo o mark zuckerberg do facebook
para aqueles alunos comum de harvard
o que diferencia o empreendedor que tem
uma ideia daquilo que realmente
empreende o que diferencia aqueles
potenciais empreendedores dos semeia
sonho para aqueles que foram escolhidos
na prática
então hoje eu vou falar pra vocês um
pouquinho dessas qualidades e
características comum empreendedores e
empreendedores de pequenas e grandes
empresas têm como o senso de
oportunidade como fazer um negócio sem
ter se á sua oportunidade
sem saber que aquele negócio já vai
gerar um bom resultado se ter aquele
feeling aquele instinto e domi 2006
quando a internet estava crescendo
existe um grande dilema existem alguns
aplicativos de troca rápida de mensagem
como sms como facebook como orkut mas
nenhum capaz de atingir um grande volume
de pessoas e um curto espaço de tempo
foi aí que desse problema foi descoberta
uma oportunidade como fazer uma
ferramenta que consiga impactar um
grande número de pessoas de forma
acessível e reflexiva
essa equipe já que torcer e se o time
tiver a idéia do twitter
o twitter surgiu justamente para
preencher essa lacuna que o facebook não
preenchia que era impactar um grande
número de pessoas um espaço pequeno de
tempo gerando um volume grande de
informação e ele enxergou isso e fez no
meio de tantas tecnologias que estavam
surgindo naquela época um aplicativo
capaz de suprir esta demanda
então aqui ele fez o ele fala que o
inesperado é uma questão de escolha
é uma questão de oportunidade que a
gente tem aqui no sêmen é sonho uma
história muito parecida à dona alzira
não virá é uma esse carro cera
trabalhava com carroça com coleta de
recicláveis
mas ela enxergava uma oportunidade na
verdade um problema dentro da sua
comunidade
é o que muitas pessoas não conseguiam
comprar um saco de arroz e um saco de
feijão
vamos supor porque as pessoas tinham
porque estava três moedas mas as pessoas
só dispunham de duas moedas
agora como resolver esse problema social
quando as pessoas só têm duas moedas mas
o curso três moedas aos vira descobriu
uma oportunidade nisso mas se as pessoas
em vez de comprar um saco de feijão um
saco de arroz e elas comprassem um
punhado de arroz e um punhado de feijão
isso não consegue ter esse problema em
conjunto com o sêmen é sonho ela começou
a descobrir esta oportunidade
ela agora criou um armazém com vendas a
granel
o que ela faz e vende pra toda sua
comunidade faz três meses que ela está
operando esse mercados mercados armazéns
com a ajuda dos e menções
ela identificou justamente de um
problema uma oportunidade a gente vê
dois casos com textos e contextos
distintos vidas diferença educação
diferente mas essas pessoas que
realmente conseguem captar a mensagem
que está no ar e fazer disso uma
oportunidade
uma outra característica muito
importante do empreendedor é a
determinação mas já viram algum
empreendedor que consigam resultados em
determinação sem acreditar naquilo que
faz insistência sem perseverança
isso é muito difícil e essa pessoa 1 16
anos eu vou comentar agora ela criou uma
revista chamada estrutura
a revista não deu muito certo na época
era uma série de razões ele era muito
jovem à final mas ele não desistiu por
aí
ele criou o segundo negócio uma loja de
discos
essa loja de discos chamava firjan
agora acho que todo mundo ficou porque é
porque ele era ele ele era virgem dos
negócios
então ele foi esse o motivo da criação
deste nome
mas esse empreendedor e não existiu ele
começou a criar novos negócios afirma
que a mega store se depois ele criou a
virgin records e ele foi para outras
áreas também
ele tentou se aventurar em uma travessia
pelo oceano atlântico a volta mais
rápida
a travessia mais rápida que tinha na
primeira não conseguiu mas na segunda
muita determinação e conseguiu ele
tentou outras façanhas como por exemplo
dar uma volta ao mundo em um balão
depois ele começou a expandir os seus
negócios
acho que agora todo mundo deve saber que
eu tô falando a virgínia hoje trabalha
com discos com viagens com a viação com
música ou jogos iene setores e se essa
pessoa é o richard branson então que ele
acredita que a determinação ela faz as
pessoas enxergarem a oportunidade que o
resultado dessa equação é justamente a
sorte sorte não se encontra sorte se
constrói a e aqui eu tenho um caso bem
semelhante uma pessoa do meio popular
que deu muito certo e conseguiu gerar
muitos frutos
ele começou como catador de um lixão e
na família muito pobre a mãe dele
acreditava que ele poderia ter muito
sucesso e ele estava lá tinha no aterro
um aterro privado catava ganhavam
dinheiro seu dia a dia e tudo o que ele
ganhava com a venda dos recicláveis ele
guardava dentro desse aterro mesmo local
específico só com um belo dia ele foi
esse local o que tinha acontecido
o aterro tinha sido vendido e levaram
tudo o que estava lá dentro
inclusive o dinheiro dele e foi aí que
ele falhou a primeira vez mas ele não
resistiu por aí porque é um cara
determinado
ele insistiu nisso que ele acredita na
determinação leva ele é construir as
melhores soluções
ele fez criou um buteco o técnico né não
deu muito certo e um belo dia button só
que na verdade era um botequim informal
netão belo dia fiscalização bateu e
fechou com o tempo que não estava
atendendo às regras exigidas pelo
mercado
e aí ele faliu a segunda vez mas esse
cara não existe esse cara é um cara
muito insistente na então o que ele fez
foi trabalhar de motoboy começou na
empresa um para que ele começou a
crescer conseguiu fazer faculdade e
virou diretor
e aí vou abrir um novo negócio é tentar
uma outra oportunidade
então ele foi fazer o que ele construiu
uma empresa de transportes
o aprendizado que ele tinha como motoboy
e aí o seguinte um belo dia uma lomba
os três caminhões
ter uma sequência todos quebraram aí ele
falhou pela terceira vez
mas ele não desiste como já falei ele é
muito determinado
então ele disso aí fez uma oportunidade
duas características importantes
ele criou uma maior empresa de
reciclagem automotiva da américa latina
estou falando aquilo geraldo rufino uma
pessoa muito determinada e que pra ele
todo mundo tem que empreender assim
mesmo importa se torna uma empresa ou se
tu é um empreendedor
agora o próximo conselho que eu quero
trazer para vocês eu tive flexibilidade
aquela capacidade de se moldar aos
diferentes contextos diferentes cenários
que se apresente
independente de onde eu estou falando
max vai ver que eu não sei se muita
gente conhece ele mas ele nasceu na
ucrânia foi estados unidos logo senussi
do número se a ele nós e ele desde o
início queria aprender e empreender não
sabia muito bem o que fazer então vou
criar uma incubadora de startup
essa foi a primeira idéia dele que foi a
minha neta startup mas o negócio não deu
muito certo estava mais parecido com um
clube de empreendedorismo ele desistiu
disso aí
só que na época onde poderia estava lá
está o crânio ele já tinha desenvolvido
algumas ferramentas para mobile de
proteção para mobile era e criou a pagar
um pacote só que essa empresa na época
não tinha muita demanda não tinha muita
lá naquela época não tinha muito paulo
então o que ele fez ele começou a
trabalhar com transferências bancárias e
criou a confidente
essa empresa desenvolveu um aplicativo
que hoje é muito conhecido para todos
pra todos nós
o paypal luta' ela ainda é uma madura e
seu foi amadurecendo
depois essa empresa confiantes hilton
conhece com ef.com do elo masc e aí deu
origem ao pepal de fato como conhecemos
depois eles venderam a empresa e ele foi
para o outro negócio porque ele quer
empreender e queria trabalhar com outras
coisas que o slide é uma empresa muito
parecida com o myspace
ela durou de 2004 2005 2011 e depois ele
vendeu por alguns milhões de dólares e
ainda continuando a carreira de
empreendedor micro sd vier que fundou a
globo é uma ferramenta
de dados para a saúde e também afirma
que é uma má é uma empresa de
financiamento em geral para empresas de
tecnologia
tá e aqui eu tenho uma história muito
semelhante do cma sonho um cara muito
flexível a ele tem uma saga muito
parecida com muitos brasileiros uma vida
muito sofrida eu ele começo teve início
de carreira pobre família pobre começou
a trabalhar numa empresa de engenharia
mas ele sempre teve a idéia de vender de
empreender para frente então ele saiu
dessa empresa começou a vender fruta é
no ceasa vendia frutas vendia na sua
comunidade mas há uma estação seca
prejudicou os negócios dele porque
começou a aumentar o custo das frutas ea
receita que ele tinha anteriormente
andava conta anos de recursos que
precisava pra viver num então ele
começou a vender alimentos em ônibus sim
naquela época dava pra vender coisa sem
ônibus hoje em dia não dá mais
então como você sabe o resultado dessa
história proibiram a venda de alimentos
em ônibus então ele teve que mudar de
novo ele foi vender resíduos coleta e
venda de resíduos reciclados com uma
carroça
só que é lei novamente entrou foi
encontro dele proibiu a circulação de
carroças em porto alegre
então seu armando agora conhecendo
projetos e menções começou a desenvolver
uma nova idéia o minimercado ambulante
do armando
e hoje o sonho dele já com a operação
desse mercado é ter uma loja de doces no
centro
então aqui ó é uma prova de que a
flexibilidade pode sim a felicidade pode
se moldar a pessoa tanto na vida
profissional quanto pessoal
então nunca assistiu ele sempre se
adaptou os problemas do dia a dia
o empreendedorismo é o projeto é meu
sonho
mostrou pra gente com o empreendedorismo
não acontece só nas garagens tecnológica
do vale do silício ela pode sim
acontecer nas comunidades com uma loja
de doces um armazém um minimercado e ela
tem o poder de transformar a realidade
de muitas
pessoas não importa onde aconteça eo
projeto sem menções surgiu justamente
para isso para dar aquele empurrãozinho
que falta para as pessoas aquelas
pessoas que têm a força de vontade mas
não conseguem aprender na prática então
a gente ajudou a transformar essas
idéias
essa vontade em negócios porque esses
são os empreendedores e meia porque
porque o empreendedorismo ele atravessa
crenças e classes gênero cor raça
religião o empreendedorismo é uma
habilidade
o empreendedorismo é um estado de
espírito
muito obrigado pessoal
[Aplausos]